being led up in the office who ran
flapper water to corporate most of our
ownership and average day period sectors
that out those average
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but you need a grounded practical engine
to this machine but I always knew I
wanted to [ __ ] like this so you know I
did about it I didn't think any of it
for the first 15 years of my life
Wow
go figure right like like like yeah
that's my action like I always had this
in me I just think that the [ __ ] was I
going to do at 22 just saying this is
what I want to do the [ __ ] that she's
going to overcome saddest carry me how
are you oh hi Gary Fraser sweet peas hey
Olivia okay say hello Frankie hello so
that's from you as a parent when do you
even think I want to share this with
Olivia if you making that point of not
caring about what other people think of
you I am tired of people not starting
and living their life on one very simple
thing which is they're worried about
what other people think Gary feels that
this is illegal in your subject it
happens slowly evil and it happened to
him then I wanted her to be comfortable
with knowing that this is quite common
it happens to everyone so there are
people out there who are prepared to
sort of say enough is enough we want to
support you through risk because the
biggest problem is it you know some days
they don't mention it and you're
actually holding yourself back so that
the message from us from or watching
both ways you don't worry at all people
think they're having someone else said
it made a big difference
you know I just want to tell you I love
you and thank you for watching my videos
and thank you as well
you're welcome - have a great day okay
mm-hmm okay keep it bad thank you so
much of Sharon's snow thank you Gary
came out taki certainly I welcome a
[Music]
universal our weekend no happy happy
thanks man
thanks guys action check this out you
guys are like this is this one thing my
mom [ __ ] lost her mom is super
morning all right go to your Apple music
app just click it and then click the
Browse button on the bottom male yeah
there I am I like apples first show is
called plan of the apps someone who are
looking at right now it's basically like
shark tank and the voice for apps and
with improv right
it wasn't acting so it was good you
should watch it now
people listen to them when they commune
or workout is the main functionality so
we're gravitating towards audio because
we become multi tasking with second
screen television watching and so now
we're valuing listening to a podcast and
doing art email and doing whatever we're
doing over watching the video version
voice is growing there's an incredible
amount of data we're looking at right
now that under 30 switching music
listening to podcasting that's crazy
right
that's just powerful it's what I love
about technology what technology does it
brings back history it brings back
history what's amazing about innovation
is it just goes in cycles so basically
what the mobile device with like that
kind of capabilities is done is got us
faster being radio listeners but there's
so much disruption coming it's the same
innovation curve always something gets
hyped but uh everybody think it's going
to happen VR oh my god VR be worse
[ __ ] 20 years away the big thing that
I want to do is get organizations and
people way more committed to technology
and like changes and the place that it's
most practical is in marketing and
creative and that's why I don't see big
companies gone I mean everybody's going
to have their moment your bucks you
retail go through over the next decade
is going so carnage holy [ __ ] these are
real stakes hungry Zach
[Music]
you don't eat up eat up eat up eat up
eat up eat up what's your name
Victor Victor thank you yeah thank you
you know cowboy unreal Thank You Man
thank you [ __ ] I'm running late to
meetings let's tag it out real quick
oh nice meet you
Thank You Man thank you say hello okay
so I'm gonna go to book an hour ago on
my social media I just said come and add
Washington Square Park and now we're
just gonna see how many people show up
you
[Music]
nobody stay with us
it's bigger like eight minutes or so
[Music]
alrighty rock now it's going to happen
[Applause]
[Music]
what's up Vlad you know this man is a
scardy episode clip it right now dear
Raksha a favor man we're so proud of
this guy I think too many people try to
figure out what their future instead of
feeling cheerful and anything you figure
it out at the time everybody's trying to
do everybody's finest figure out chips
beforehand the answer is the figure [ __ ]
out after the people you spend time with
are the ones that dictate your mindset
such as 100 percent
Jim is sly I love you love you food
welcome in a make the steak happy so
like blogging you dance for everyone no
I think I think everyone should try it
because if you're documenting and not
creating everybody can do it I just
think that 99% of people aren't
interesting so when what I think it's
for everybody worked flying because the
cost of entry is super low and I just
think most people don't have anything to
say or aren't doing anything interesting
no matter what you're about to say you
can't win in vlogging if it's about the
cool thing is because you can't do
enough cool things you weren't in
vlogging because you connect with people
you just said I don't even [ __ ] know
what you're [ __ ] talking about but we
can it right so by the way I could but
but that doesn't mean you got to be high
energy and ridiculous like me that's
just my treat
you might be [ __ ] Thomas [ __ ] mundane
like they usually connect and a lot of
people just go know if they're they've
got the face or the vibe or the
connection or a story that connects with
other people and I think it's worth try
it
I figured be subdivide if you don't do
what you want to do you're going to end
up regretting it which is then going to
manifest at being mad at them and you
were doing a greater this service for
the relationship of you and your parents
by not doing what you want to do and by
doing what they want you to do there's a
seed of what you actually want to do
you're hiding that seed because you love
your parents so much right you're going
to then do that and then you may be 42
and not have the chance to do your thing
and you're gonna be mad at them and
you're to blame them for it and then
it's going to hurt your relationship not
how then I think if you if it's so deep
inside of you to give you need to decide
you can only give when you have
something to give and you have stability
in that giving that could be consistent
so you let like I always say like you've
been you selfishly happy before you
worry about everybody else because you
won't have anything to give if you're
not good
you have the same voice with you and you
kind of a mentor here and I really
appreciate your good intent they do and
that you're trying to put this to do
this good thing in business like it
really drives me thanks to you I started
to pay your Amazon yeah right now
designing t-shirts your arch yes and I
really love you and you like you know
this thing that you try to change the
world
you're better yeah it just keeps me
love questions as well right there thank
you
I started out my summer I was like I'm
going to make music all summer but I
have not been able to just get off my
ass and so what are you doing in second
watching just now I got to be honest I
don't think that was the best part of
the whole night and just that truth is
real there's a there's a deeper reason
you know yeah right it's because you
either don't really believe in your
music or like I'm trying to perfect it
too much the [ __ ] is perfection like
there's just a lot of bigger reasons to
why you're not doing it perfections the
disguise of insecurity yeah you told me
people believe I do believe you can I
love you I mean that from the bottom of
my heart because I like you so much Adam
what are you doing driving taxi means no
excuses to spend no time and energy on
how you got there just spend all of it
on getting yourself out of there
it's just time and energy good luck
sorry I'm not here yeah yeah
friends of scary B listen it's like
talking 1 o'clock in the morning I'm
trying to leave and this means like yo
can you make a [ __ ] video for my
friend my friend yourself Gary guys
Thank You Megan oh yeah got seconds
well 43 in the morning
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]